talking about animals that are [ __ ]
[ __ ]
were we talking about that i i just i'm
going with this weird [ __ ] tangent
now
but why does [ __ ] everyone idolize
swans or like
what why why are swansea i don't know
i'm pretty sure swan the nerd is like
pretty [ __ ] violent
yeah okay because like every because i
grew up like
you know i i grew up no no i grew up
with this in this image that you know
swans were these
majestic [ __ ] birds they're the
queen's bird you know
like you know isn't it true that like
the queen owns everything yeah every
swan
yeah yeah but they're such [ __ ] kids
saying that
well they're like they're like geese
aren't they like you know they like
they look fine
have you seen their mouths it's like a
like a serrated like
cylinder it's terrifying it's insane
swans and nerfed geese
no because like swans like i remember my
first memory of the swan because i
thought it was just like a
like a beautiful looking duck and like
ducks are cool ducks yeah [ __ ] are nice
ducks are cute as [ __ ] so as a as like a
four-year-old kid i remember like
looking at the swan i was like that kind
of looks like a duck like let's let's
let's let's try phoenix
see what happens like so i get close to
it with like the bird food
[ __ ] starts like [ __ ] jabbing my
nose i'm like [ __ ] attacking me
i love it when they like open their
wings
i don't know why it just reminded me of
that video you showed me what was it
called it was like the video title was
literally called
uh ducks annihilating a bowl of peas
it's literally just what the video says
it's like this 30 second video of this
guy with just a bowl of peas
and these two ducks come and then they
literally annihilate
this ball like like it's just the word
annihilator because you're like
because you're like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about ducks can't annihilate
a bowl of peas and you see this video
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] violated
please look it up it's hilarious i knew
how to get away from that krakatoa what
about bird
ducks eating some peas what do you want
to talk about chris what are you going
to talk about that's not crack at all
i don't know anymore i just don't know
what's been on your mind lately
everything
tell me what's been on damage
agony aunt connor i don't think so the
worst agony on he's the [ __ ] uncle
agony uncle more like
me yeah horrible
what what what animal are you afraid of
[ __ ]
i don't know because to me it sounds
like you're afraid of every animal i'm a
friend no
i love all animals you're fighting
[ __ ] horses they're [ __ ] gonna
kick you in the face yeah
anything could kick you in the face and
it'll probably hurt
and it can lie on you and you'd probably
die
one is more likely to kill your horse
kicking your face or a cow lying on you
who scared ways to die by it's farming
hard that needs to happen
pigs with shotguns now